hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now we'll start with the big one
it comes to an end today after four days
of climate protest in central London
tens of thousands of people took part in
the event organized by extension
rebellion in Coalition with around 200
other groups with each day having its
own theme today is choose your own
future and not only does it Mark the end
of the protest but it could be the end
of the group's new less disruptive
approach to activism as the deadline
they gave the government to act on
climate change well it approaches five
o'clock our climate and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter joins
me now
um Hannah so let's talk about the
demands from the group what do they want
from the government
well what they said is they want the UK
to stop approving new oil and gas
extraction in the North Sea or anywhere
but mainly in the North Sea and they
also want the government to create an
emergency citizens assembly to give the
people more say in how to tackle the
climate change
issue now it's of course very unlikely
the government's going to do anything of
the sort in fact they're pursuing a
strategy that's completely opposite of
what Extinction Rebellion is asking for
the government is in fact expanding oil
and gas extraction in the UK in the
North Sea they see it as critical to
their energy security policies and they
have been asked for a number of years
now to create emergency citizens
assemblies and they've done nothing of
the sort so we can assume the 5 PM
deadline is going to come and go what
next well Extinction rebellion and
others there are other groups in this
Coalition that have joined here for this
four days of protest well they say
they're going to do more now if the
government ignores them to support
Strikers around the country and
separately they're going to start
thinking about stepping up a new
campaign of Civil Disobedience I think
we'll see that from just stop oil who've
already decided for the next uh
indefinitely is what they've said every
day they're going to do slow marches and
block major roads in the capital and
Beyond and other members of the broader
Extinction Rebellion group are going to
now have a think about what they can
Target and when in order to step up the
campaign a bit but it is worth saying
they're really very aware that gluing
themselves to things blocking roads
stopping people getting to work in
particular created a real public
backlash which is why earlier in the
year Extinction Rebellion said it was
going to step away from those kinds of
tactics and that's what we've seen here
actually a real diversity of people
attending these protests the organizers
say around a hundred thousand people
have been here over the last four days
and plenty of people who've come to
these protests for the first time
and it comes doesn't it Hannah on the
big day the government announces plans
of this this power line connecting the
UK with the Netherlands what do we know
about that
so this is the lion link it's a new
interconnector which would connect not
just the UK and the Netherlands together
but the UK and the Netherlands to the
same wind farms and it's pretty unusual
there's only one other in the world like
it it's considered to be the gold
standard for power sharing between
allies it allows a great deal of
flexibility so when one country needs
the electricity the other can stop and
vice versa they can take electricity
from the wind farms if the turbines are
turning and it doesn't get wasted
because of course we don't have the
battery storage capacity right now to
store excess renewable energy and this
is all coming out of the North Sea
Summit which is happening in Belgium the
UK has been invited to it the first time
the lion link which could provide
electricity for up to 2 million homes is
just one of the announcements but we do
understand there may be further
announcements coming out this evening
potentially around a trading deal with
Denmark and then there might be
something else as well about a new
commitment between the North Sea Nations
to dramatically expand offshore wind
power in particular by creating turbine
Islands out in the North Sea okay Hannah
thanks so much for that update let's
take a look at some other stories making
news today and in Berlin climate
activists well they tried to bring
traffic to a standstill this morning by
gluing themselves to streets all over
the capital they had delayed the start
of the all-electric Formula E race on
Sunday at warning we're on the highway
to the climate of hell they're from the
group called the last generation and
they climb the fence and SATs in front
of cars on the starting grid
well new research has found that
government plans for UK energy
Independence can't be met by drilling
for more gas in the North Sea without
reducing demand the energy and climate
intelligence units say under current
plans the Nets Imports of gas Will Rise
by almost 60 percent by 2035 It also
says the ramping up of new tech like
heat pumps will reduce the country's
over all Reliance on gas
The National Trust has kicked off its
first ever Blossom week encouraging
people to go outside and Marvel at the
flowers now the trust says the UK is
currently at the epicenter of a blossom
boom following the driest February in 30
years
now the carbon footprint of Industries
have put sectors such as power and steel
in the spotlight as major contributors
to climate change and although the
technology to Aid transition to Net Zero
is available well it's expensive and
needs investment and that's where the
crucial role of the financial sector
comes into play and it's the first topic
of discussion among Financial leaders in
London today our business presenter Ian
King has the latest on the mood for
sustainable investment from the city
welcome to Guild Hall here in the heart
of the city of London where I'm here for
an event being hosted by the corporation
of London city week it's a get-together
of a thousand industry Leaders The Great
and good of the financial services
industry and the key discussions on the
matters of the day now are the three
main themes this year one is
digitalization another is digital assets
and the third is climate change and
there have been a number of discussions
here today around how to fund the
transition to Net Zero I've been
speaking with Lord Brown he's chair of
Beyond zero and of course also former
chief executive of BP where he was very
much a Pioneer in looking at non-carbon
energy and one of the things that he
told me is that some four trillion
dollars is going to be required to fund
this transition I asked him where that
money was going to come from and about
the appetite of investors towards that
here's what he told me
that's an enormous amount of money it
needs the right incentives the
measurements and it needs a great blend
of public and private finance and I made
the point the thing about private
finances it comes with companies and
companies of the best vehicle in the
world to deliver and they've got to
deliver against measurable outcomes and
so we've got plenty more to do
incentives are very good things taxes
are also good but in the U.S incentives
work better to actually push investment
into things like carbon capture and
storage energy storage
these sorts of things very important
indeed so we need to emulate that around
the world
so that was Lord brown one of the key
figures in the financial services sector
and of course the energy industry I
think the good news is that there is a
willingness and a desire among investors
to fund this transition I think the
bigger question is whether that
willingness is going to meet with the
time scale demanded by the public
now just before we go a reminder to
watch the climate Show with Tom Heat
this weekend on Saturday and Sunday at 3
P.M and 7 30 pm